one of the first formal studies of the  phenomenon was at Harvard Medical School  in the year 2000  participants played the game for seven  hours each spread over the course of  three days  remarkably 63% of the participants  almost two-thirds reported seeing  imagery from the game hours after they  finished playing often just as they were  falling asleep this fact on its own was  news with  even more surprising  and music patience  damage that prevents them from forming  new memories  reported seeing game imagery well after  they'd finished playing these  participants were unable to recall  having ever played begin but their  descriptions match  of players with perfect memories blocks  they all saw  falling through space sometimes  fitting neatly into empty spaces between  other planets some participants also  reported seeing completed lines  disappear  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  the cleanest  [Music]  the researchers gave this phenomenon the  name  [Music]  please